This video is sponsored by Henson Shaving.
What do Ikea founder Ingvar Kamprad
Sir Richard Branson
Billionaire investor Charles Schwab
Walt Disney
And Henry Ford have in common?
All are or were successful entrepreneurs
with dyslexia – a learning disorder that
makes it very difficult to read, write, and spell.
People with dyslexia have trouble
connecting the letters they see
to the sounds they make and as a
result, often struggle in school.
But in the real world, they thrive. They're behind
some of the most successful companies on Earth.
Richard Branson is one of the
greatest entrepreneurs of our time.
He created numerous businesses under the Virgin
umbrella and has a net worth of $5 billion.
Virgin which now employs 90,000 people would not
have been successful if I hadn’t been dyslexic.
If you had told Branson’s classmates
that he’d achieve this stunning level
of success in life - they
may have been dumbfounded.
Branson was seen as “the dumbest
person in school” - in his words.
He had a hard time keeping up with
his peers because of his dyslexia
and dropped out at the age of 16.
Yet he transformed his weakness into an advantage.
Branson credits dyslexia with his success
because he adapted his management style to
suit it which he feels made him a better boss.
He understood the importance
of communicating well.
He’s famous for being an inspirational
leader who engages with people.
And his dyslexia also forced him to
delegate tasks to those who excelled
in the areas where he was weak.
I had to surround myself with great
people. Because I wasn’t good at
maths or something, I had to
find people who were good at it.
One example is when he hired an accountant
during the early days of Virgin.
He credits that with getting
the company off the ground.
Branson always struggled with numbers and words.
Once, when he was in a board meeting at the age of
50, he couldn’t for the life of him understand
the difference between net and gross profit.
Another person in the room kindly took him aside
and explained it to him with an illustration.
He drew the ocean. And put a net
in the ocean with fish in it.
He explained that the fish in
the net were the net profits,
and the rest of the ocean was the gross turnover.
And then everything became clear to Branson.
Delegating tasks to the right people
is essential to growing any business.
Yet many find it difficult to give up control.
Everyone knows of a boss who’s a micromanager!
Research has found people with dyslexia
are more likely to delegate authority
and also twice as likely to
own two or more businesses.
That study out of Cass Business
School in London found more than
a third of American entrepreneurs
surveyed showed signs of dyslexia.
Another commissioned by the BBC found 40% of that
country’s self-made millions showed
some signs of the learning disability.
That's significantly higher than
the estimated 5% to 10% of the
general population with some degree of dyslexia.
The question is: Are their entrepreneurial
strengths a result of nature or nurture?
A dyslexia expert believes they are
naturally better at certain things,
like picking up social cues.
In an article in the Sacramento Bee about
California governor Gavin Newsom who has dyslexia,
Dr. Marilu Gorno-Tempini of UC San Francisco said:
“He can understand what people need
and their emotions more than others.
I don’t think that’s a compensation. I think
that’s the superpower of his dyslexic brain.”
She and other scientists at UC San Francisco
recently discovered children with the disorder
had greater changes in heart rate and
facial behavior when they viewed video
clips of others experiencing emotions
compared to children without dyslexia.
Eleanor Palser, one of the researchers who
conducted the study, concluded to Newsthink:
“This tells us that dyslexia might be associated
with biological differences in empathy…”
Being able to see things from
the other person's perspective
is extremely important for any entrepreneur.
Walt Disney, who was diagnosed with
dyslexia, could read people very well
and was extremely empathetic
according to those who knew him.
He dreamt up a world that children and adults
could enjoy and transformed Disney into an empire.
Turns out, the brains of people
with dyslexia are wired differently.
University of Cambridge researchers
used artificial intelligence to map
out the brain differences of hundreds of children.
They discovered those with dyslexia had
poorly connected “hubs” within the brain
which they attributed to
their learning difficulties.
You can liken these hubs to a train station
with few or poorly organized connections.
So people with dyslexia literally have a
different way of thinking and seeing the world.
Their unique brains are believed
to make them brilliant spies.
In fact, some intelligence agencies are
actively recruiting people with dyslexia,
such as the UK’s GCHQ.
The agency calls their
thinking skills “mission critical” because
they’re great at spotting patterns that
others don’t see - crucial in trying to
prevent acts of terrorism for example.
And increasingly important with
warfare moving into cyberspace.
As AI and machine learning automate
routine tasks, creative thinking
skills could be in higher demand.
And their creativity apparently
leads to original ideas that translate into
million-dollar or billion-dollar success.
No matter what business you’re in, the goal
is to make the product as good as possible.
That brings me to the sponsor of this video,
Henson Shaving, the maker of high-quality
safety razors that I personally use.
They know a thing or two about making a great
product because their razors are manufactured
out of the same machine shop in Canada that
built parts for the International Space Station.
The blade of a Henson only sticks out
about half the thickness of a human hair
there's less vibration, which
results in much less irritation.
I used to use disposable razors but I
realized it made sense to own a re-usable one.
Henson Shaving has a special
promotion just in time for Christmas.
If you use my discount code: NEWSTHINK
you’ll get a pack of 100 blades for FREE.
Be sure to add the 100-pack to your
shopping cart before using my code.
And if you feel like treating yourself, they
recently came out with their Titanium razor.
Henson ships all around the world.
If you'd like to try one out,
you can head to my custom link in the description
Thanks for watching. For Newsthink, I’m Cindy Pom.